Speaker 1: All right, this is truly one of
my favorite Pfeil clips from the last week
on the Fox News show Fox and Friends Steve
Doocy, who has never struck anybody as being
particularly with it.
Let's be honest about about do you see he
tried citing the number of covid deaths and
people affected nationally by the virus, but
what came out of his mouth didn't make any
sense.
And he sort of seems to realize it.
Now, you may know that in the United States,
more than 33 million people have officially
gotten the virus.
The real number is probably more like 65 million,
and more than 600000 people officially have
died.
And yet in this segment, Steve Doocy says
here in the U.S., fifty two thousand people
have died and two million people have been
affected by covid.
And as he sees it, you see a sort of strange
look on his face.
And at one point he looks off screen to his
right, almost as if someone's flagging him,
as if he realizes that what he's saying makes
no sense, but he just can't seem to get back
on track.
So check it out.
Speaker 3: Think about it this way, folks.
Here in the United States of America, fifty
two thousand Americans have died from covid.
Fifty two thousand.
I was shocked to see that.
Thirty three thousand of them actually live
here in New York City, which is shocking.
Two million Americans have been impacted.
So how did it come to infect the entire planet?
Speaker 1: So this, of course, makes no sense.
And what appears to have happened is that
Deucy was trying to give the covid numbers
for New York State, not for the United States,
which are close to the numbers he gave in
the state of New York.
Indeed, fifty three thousand people have died
of the virus, about two point one million
official cases.
And later in the show, Deucy corrected himself.
He was apparently confused and he is also
a clown.
The correction hilariously came during a segment
about what else, of course, cancel culture.
Now, a ton of people wrote to me saying, David,
this isn't a mistake.
This was, as usual, trying to throw in a low
number and then correcting so that it doesn't
look as though Trump failed is bad.
No, I don't think so.
I think this was just a mistake.
I think Deucy didn't realize that the numbers
he was giving made no sense until he said
it and then he sort of realized it.
I don't believe that this is nefarious.
I think it's the constant confusion happening
at Fox News and the constant confusion going
on in the brain of Steve Doocy.
The only strange thing about the clip is that
no one immediately said in his earpiece, New
York, not us, New York, not not us, and that
he could have immediately corrected and said,
sorry, that's in New York State, not in the
United States.
That is weird.
I admit that I don't have an explanation for
that.
But this is actually an opportunity to remind
you the official numbers are nowhere near
the real estimated number of covid cases and
deaths.
And there's a lot of different reasons for
this.
First, we can talk about cases, then we can
talk about deaths.
One study suggests that cases which are officially
33 million could be two to three times that
number.
So 33 million official cases, the real US
number could be sixty six million or ninety
nine million.
Why?
A bunch of different reasons.
Early on, before we even knew about this virus
as a separate virus from the flu, there were
tons of people who had symptoms.
There were no tests available at that point
in time or not.
Enough tests they tested for flu, came back
negative and just were told, go home.
It's probably some virus.
That's a whole bunch of people.
In January 20, 20, February 20, 20, March,
even into April, I don't exactly remember.
Was it end of April, early May, when testing
really ramped up?
So there's a whole bunch of people who tested
negative for the flu or never got a test whatsoever.
Also, ton of asymptomatic cases.
Now, the relevance of an asymptomatic case,
you might say.
Well, we didn't capture in the data a lot
of those asymptomatic cases, but they also
don't really matter.
OK, that's a that's a debate.
But that's another reason why the 33 million
number is very low.
People who had an asymptomatic case or an
almost asymptomatic case may never have thought
to get tested.
So real number of cases, anywhere from two
to three times the official number deaths.
One study suggests that the real number of
covid deaths could be not two to three times
the official number, but could be 30 to 40
percent higher than the official number one
study says it could be 50 percent higher.
How could that be a bunch of different reasons?
One, there is a degree to which sometimes
someone dies and it's just not being reported
locally as a covid death number two there.
Are people who died in their homes where they
were never posthumously tested for covid and
they are sort of what we would call presumed
cases, but not necessarily known cases.
So also a multiplier if you take the official
number of covid deaths, if you want to get
to the real number, maybe you multiply by
one point three, one point four, maybe one
point five.
So, Steve Doocy.
Yes, constant confusion going on there, whatever.
But an opportunity to remind you that even
when we look at the official numbers and we
say here's how bad it was and we make a judgment
about that, the real numbers are probably
30 to 50 percent more deaths and two to three
times more cases